こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーと
どうもこんばんは
カリスマブラザーズの
痛い痛い
皆さん年末ということなんですけども
みんなで集まる機会というのは多いと思うのですよ
親戚とか家族とかね
集まる機会多いと思うのですけども
人が集まると
ピザ食べたくありませんか？
ピザかー食べたい!
ピザが食べたいのですけども
ピザ屋さんの人も
毎回そのピザを、何回も何回も
いろいろな人に運んで
もう、たまったもんじゃないと思うのですよ
楽しくないと思うのです。ピザ届けてても
なるほど
お客さんに渡して、お金もらって帰るだけ
そんな繰り返しでね
もうピザ屋さんもね
なるほど
そう。僕は、そういうピザ屋さんの人たちにも
ハピネスをあげたいので
今日は
ピザ屋さんの人に・・・
ドッキリをしようと思います
内容なんですけども
先ほどちょっといろいろ買ってきました
で、これ突っ張り棒をちょっと買ってきたのですけど
痛い
二つ買ってきました
で、これは
このうまい棒
うまい棒?
この突っ張り棒体重制限が
70Kgまであるので
僕の体重が65Kgなので
この二つをぶら下がっておけば
まず僕は140Kgより下、65Kgなので
乗れます
乗れる、乗れる
で、それプラス
強いロープを買ってきました
これ多分見てわかると思うのですけども
こういう風になんかこう言う...何か
ヤバいやつを運ぶのですよ
これで
というわけで
今回の作戦としては
このカリスマブラザーズの三人に
ロープで
僕をつるして上げてもらって
三人に引っ張ってもらいます
ピザ屋さんきて
俺が普通に座って待っているわけじゃないですか
「ピンポーン」と押して入ると
うん
で、「ピザでーす」てピザ渡すじゃないですか
でお会計してる時に
僕、勝手に宙に浮くのですよ
はははははははは
そういうことね
ロープでこうなってて
三人が引いてくれたら
お会計中に僕が浮き出すのですよ
いきなり
なるほど
ハッピーですよ
年末なんでね
いろんな人を笑顔にしたいと思っています
早速ピザを
注文していこうと思います
すいませんピザ食べたいのですけど
はい、はい
おぉー
じゃあそれでお願いします
メンズが四人いるんですけど
お気を付けておこしください
ありがとうございます
はい
失礼します
ピザ頼みましたよ
早速
準備に取り掛かります
では行こう
ここに
こう二つ引っ掛けて
三人が裏で引いてもらう
なるほど
硬くなってきた
割とガチで頑丈に留めます
そこでそっとそっち締めて
引っ張れる?これ
ヤバい時間との戦いだ
なんで頼んじゃったのだろう
うわーーーーー
ロープを準備していきたいと思います
はいというわけで
一応がっつり
締めました
70Kg,70Kgで
もう
140Kgに耐えられる状態でございます
じゃあここからちょっと
僕がロープを付けにいきましょう
短いよ
これ短いぞ
いいねいいね
ゆっくり
ひゅーー
ウィスパーの方だね
オッケーです
ばれないところで後ろからひっぱいっていただきます
オッケー
「ピンポーン」
こんばんは
お会計が4266円になります
えっと
4266円
一万円でもいいですか?
うわっ
いいですか?
ありがとうございました
まぁ多分楽しんでくれたかなとは
面白かった
ハッピーは届けられた
アメリカから
今カリスマブラザーズさんが来てるので
ぜひみんな
いやいや
チャンネル登録してね
なんでだよ
じゃーな